Okay, so welcome back to the screen.
Welcome to video number 14. We are going
to continue looking at our leading
indicators internationally. And now we're
going to be looking in China. And we're
going to be looking at the China official
and Kaixin China manufacturing PMIs.
Let's refer back for a moment to our
leading indicator dashboard. Yes, we have
our US leading indicators on the left hand
side. And we have our international
leading indicators on the right hand side.
In the last video, we included the
European economic sentiment indicator into
our international surveys list. Now, we're
going to be adding China manufacturing
PMIs,
the official and Kaixin number. And we're
also going to be looking at Chinese real
interest rates. Now, in the downloads
area, you're going to find a couple of
supporting spreadsheets for this video.
Open them up. We're going to be looking at
China manufacturing PMIs. And we'll be
looking also at real interest rates in
China.
In China as well. If you recall, from
previous videos, when we looked at GDP
lead tables, you'll recall that China in
2019 was at 14.731 trillion US dollars.
And they're ranked number two behind the
US in global GDP. And catching up to the
US.
In the US, the growth rate has actually
slowed in China in the last decade from
officially 10.5% GDP growth in 2010 to
around 8% in 2021. Now, the 8% in 2021,
it's debatable whether that's long-term
sustainable. It is a bit of a rebound from
2020, being a low year.
For obvious reasons. So the range for the
last five years in China has been 2.3% in
2020 as a low and the high of 8.1% in
2021. The normal, if we want to call it
that, pre-COVID-19 GDP growth rate of
China has been around 6% to 7%.
Now, it's a well-known secret fact that
Chinese GDP stats are very heavily
manipulated due to the reporting lines set
up in the country. And from a trader and
portfolio manager perspective, this
creates a lot of problems for us. Because
our usual lines of inquiry, so utilizing
GDP growth forecasts to forecast stock
market
that stock market direction and potential
returns don't work. So, in China, we can't
use Chinese GDP as a predictor of the
Shanghai Composite, the Shenzhen Component
Index, or even the Hong Kong, the Hang
Seng Index, as likely stock market
direction and returns.
So, if you recall from way earlier in the
video series, when we did our quadnomial
analysis of China, so Chinese GDP and
stock market direction, on a quarterly
basis, you'll recall that moving in the
same direction came in at around 55%, 56%,
and moving in the opposite direction came
in at around 44%, 45% of quarters.
So, of the total 113 case quarters, which
basically means that they move in the
opposite direction, almost as much as they
move in the same direction. And you'll
also recall that the main reason why they
don't move in the same direction is the
0-1 situation, where the index is reported
down for the quarter, and GDP growth is
reported as positive.
So, up for the quarter. So, up for the
quarter. So, this happens 40% of quarters
in history, which is almost as much as the
1-1 situation, which is 46% of quarters in
history.
So, you'll also remember the week
correlation number as well. So, where the
correlation number came in very, very low
for the six-month lag. So, that's
something to remember and recall as well.
So, if 40% of quarters, the Shenzhen
Component Index is reported down, but
Chinese GDP growth is up. Why is that?
Well, it's mainly because GDP stats are
manipulated and Chinese indices have low
to meaningless correlation with GDP growth
because of it.
So, when we're forecasting Chinese GDP
growth and potentially looking to take
positions in Chinese indices, it's a bit
of a fruitless and thankless, naive task
to go about doing that.
So, let's have a look at some of these
reasons why a Chinese index like the
Shenzhen Component Index can go down, but
Chinese GDP goes up.
Well, first of all, we have to look at
GDP, both internally and externally.
Internally, there's 431 provinces in China
and 3,418 prefectures that report GDP.
And prefectures report to provinces and
provinces report to the federal level, so
central government.
Local officials in the provinces and the
prefectures need to show GDP growth for
their own individual promotional
prospects.
And they achieve this by either outright
manipulation or pushing through
last-minute government infrastructure
projects to boost the local GDP number.
And this GDP number, this volume doesn't
necessarily end up being reflected in
publicly listed company earnings.
So, internally, GDP numbers can be
manipulated, thus weakening the
correlation between GDP growth and the
stock market.
So, externally, so external GDP, if you
recall, 19% of the Chinese economy is
exports and 19% of those exports are to
the US and 19% to the European Union.
They are the largest export clients of
China and 50% of their exports goes to
other Asian countries.
Now, when the US and the EU don't grow, so
they have very low GDP growth or flat GDP
growth or even a contraction, or in the
case where we have, for example, US trade
tariffs, like under the Trump
administration,
Chinese GDP can just be manipulated by the
controlling party, the CCP, in order to
maintain the illusion of control, in order
to stay in power and have power in the
country.
So, as traders and portfolio managers, if
we see the US and Europe slowing down and
we think this is going to be a knock-on
effect to Chinese GDP and Chinese indices,
it's not necessarily the case because
China can actually still manipulate its
figures to maintain this illusion of
control over the economy.
Further reasons for the correlation break.
There is no pensions infrastructure in
China like there is in the United States.
And the dynamics of the middle class are
very different in China to Western nations
and Western geographies like the US and
the EU.
So, we've all heard the statistic that
China has lifted 700 million people out of
poverty in the last decade.
Well, there's a problem with that
statistic.
The poverty rate or the poverty measure 10
years ago was measured as being
individuals living on less than $3 per
day.
In the modern day, in today's world, there
are still over 700 million people living
on less than $4 a day and a lot more
living on less than $10 a day.
So, yes, the poverty definition of living
on less than $3 a day, 700 million people
may have been lifted above that number,
but they're still poor.
There's still widespread poverty.
China's demographics and wealth is
basically polarized between Beijing,
Shanghai and big city elites versus the
rural and urban persons in poverty.
The middle class is emerging there, but it
doesn't work like the US and Europe, where
the middle class is much bigger as a
percentage of the population.
The population is extremely polarized in
its wealth dynamics.
Unlike the US and Europe, there is no
pensions infrastructure like IRAs and
401ks.
So, what does that mean?
If you have a very small middle class and
you have no pensions infrastructure, it's
not like the US where pension funds are
buying on the behalf of pensions holders
the stock market every month.
So, in the Western world, in the US in
particular, people are paying money into
their pensions every month and the
pensions manager is using that money to
then go and buy the stock market every
month.
So, what does this do?
It guarantees a monthly buyer of the stock
market, which obviously puts a floor under
the market.
It puts a floor under the stock market.
In China, this doesn't even exist.
So, low middle class and no pensions
infrastructure means there's no guaranteed
monthly buyer of any Chinese indices, of
the Chinese stock market.
Additionally, we all know China has a very
large population.
That's the current population though.
There's very little population growth.
The single child policy, although it's now
ended, has meant that in the past, due to
there being no population growth, the
internal economy in China does have a
consumer headwind.
So, via labor force growth and consumer
spending growth.
So, consumer capacity is limited.
Generally speaking, the more people you
have, the more people you have in your
labor force.
So, you have a larger labor force capacity
and participation.
And of course, you have more consumers,
therefore more consumer spending.
But if you're not making any more people,
you don't get any of that.
Additionally, in the stock markets in
China, there's a lot of rules, a lot of
regulations.
It makes it very difficult for
international investors and domestic
investors.
And therefore, the knock-on effect in
Chinese stocks and indices means a very
fragmented market that is low correlation
to GDP.
There's limited foreign purchases for
Chinese stocks.
So, the Shanghai Composite, the SSE,
comprises of what's known as China A
shares.
And the Shenzhen Component Index is China
B shares.
So, China A shares are primarily for
domestic investors only and denominated in
RMB, the local currency.
And China B shares are for primarily
institutional foreign investors
denominated in currencies like the US
dollar.
And if foreigners are purchasing A shares,
it has to be an institution.
So, foreign purchases of A shares are
restricted to qualified foreign
institutional investors.
Now, domestic buyers can't buy B shares.
So, for foreign institutional investors, B
shares don't see regular and increasing
levels of investment as GDP grows.
So, using B shares, so for foreign
investors or A shares, that's for domestic
investors, as an instrument to predict GDP
growth is basically a thankless task.
Now, for retail traders, the only true way
for retail traders to gain exposure to
Chinese stocks is via single stock ADRs in
the US.
So, American depository receipts listed in
the US, or via single stocks in the Hang
Seng China Enterprise Index, the HSCEI
listed in Hong Kong.
Now, obviously, for international retail
traders, ADRs and ETFs listed in the US
are by far a better option for those
retail traders.
So, for all of the shenanigans that
surround Chinese GDP growth, how do we
even tell if China is really growing or
not?
Well, the best way to do this is to look
at non-Chinese government manipulated
figures.
As traders and PMs, this is the best we
can do.
And we have to make a reasonable attempt
here at forecasting Chinese GDP growth in
order to not, obviously, predict it using
the Chinese indices,
but to do so to fill in the global macro
picture and perhaps to have trade ideas in
Chinese listed stocks in the US.
So, Chinese ADRs and ETFs.
Now, in China, there are two main
purchasing manager index surveys.
There's the Chinese official manufacturing
PMI and the CAICSIN manufacturing PMI.
And there's also non-manufacturing data.
That's both, open quotes, official and
sponsored by CAICSIN.
So, we are going to be concentrating on
manufacturing, the non-manufacturing or
services PMI.
The data doesn't go back a long time,
doesn't have a long history.
But every month that goes by, every year
that goes by, obviously, that data will
become more important.
So, here in this video, we're going to
focus on manufacturing.
And we have to remember as well, the
Chinese official PMI stats can also be
manipulated to paint a false picture of
reality.
And there's been many times when
international investors have seriously
questioned the official stats when they've
been released.
As traders and PMs, we prefer to look at
the non-official data, so non-government
sponsored.
We look at the CAICSIN data, which is
provided by IHS market and sponsored by
CAICSIN.
And what we do is, as traders and
portfolio managers, every month when the
data is released, we focus on the CAICSIN
China manufacturing PMI data.
But what we also do is we look at the
differences between the CAICSIN data and
the official data.
And this gives us a gauge, not only on a
more realistic outlook of potential
Chinese GDP growth coming from the CAICSIN
number,
but also because when we look at the
differences in the two, we can gauge how
much the government is potentially lying
about their data.
Now, in terms of a survey design of the
CAICSIN China manufacturing PMI, it's
compiled by IHS market, as I mentioned.
And it's a survey with responses to
questionnaires that are sent out to
purchasing managers of around 500 private
and state owned manufacturers.
So what do we notice there? Well, we do
have state owned manufacturers as well in
there.
And obviously that can make even the
CAICSIN China manufacturing PMI
questionable.
So we have to be also a little bit careful
with the CAICSIN data, but it's way more
reliable on the reality of the situation
in China than the government data,
because even the state owned purchasing
managers at the state owned manufacturers,
they're not reporting to the government.
They're reporting to IHS market. They're
reporting to a private entity outside of
China.
So the survey responses that IHS market
get are collected in the second half of
each month and indicate the direction of
change compared to the previous month.
And yes, it's a diffusion index like our
US ISM, and it's calculated for each
survey variable.
The index is the sum of the percentage of
higher responses and half the percentage
of unchanged responses.
Now our old friend, the 50 level is our
important indicator level again, similar
to US ISM leading indicators.
So our range is between 0 and 100 and a
reading above 50 indicates an overall
increase compared to the previous month
and below 50 an overall decrease.
And then indices are seasonally adjusted.
So the headline figure is the purchasing
managers index.
And the PMI, the headline number, the
aggregate is a weighted average of five
indices.
We have new orders at 30%, output 25%,
employment 20%, supplier delivery times
15%, and stocks of purchases 10%.
And the underlying survey data are not
revised after the publication.
But there may be seasonal adjustment
factors to revise from time to time.
And they do this as appropriate, which may
affect the seasonally adjusted data in the
past.
Now in the downloads area, you're going to
find all of the data, the historical data
for Chinese GDP, both nominal and real.
So you'll see the CPI data there for
China.
So you'll have inflation adjusted economic
growth.
So you have nominal and real GDP data.
And you'll also have in the downloads, the
Kaixin and the official China
manufacturing PMI data as well.
So you'll have the whole data set there.
And what you'll find is some chart
analysis on the data itself.
And we can look at this all of our
indicators visually.
And let's go through them on the screen.
So first of all, on the screen, we have
the official China manufacturing PMI.
So this is from the National Bureau of
Statistics.
This is from the government.
And you can see visually that there's some
very obvious peaks and drops and trend
occurring.
So we can see going back into the
pre-financial crisis period.
So 05 to 08, 09.
The pre-financial crisis period, 05, 07.
You can see that we had periods of the
official number that was in the high 50s
and above 55.
Since then, and definitely in the period
after the financial crisis leading out of
it, so between 2010 and 2020, for an
entire decade, we never really got
readings above the 55 level.
You can see the peaks, obviously
historically, back then in the
pre-financial crisis period, the official
data peaking in the high 50s.
The overall data set troughs tend to occur
between the 35 and 40 level.
What's also interesting, if you eyeball
the last decade, you can see that there's
a pretty defined,
pretty defined top when it comes to
reporting expansion in the official China
manufacturing PMI.
In particular, if you look at the periods,
for example, in 2016, 2017, 2018, you can
see multiple readings between 50 and 52.
So lots of readings of 50, 51 and 52.
And then we tend to peak at 52.
And then in the 2020 year, we get the
recovery of COVID, and then we peaked
again at 52.
So around 52 level seems to be over the
last five, six, seven years, a kind of
peak for reporting expansion for the
official China manufacturing PMI.
In the download, you'll also find an
analysis on the changes on a month by
month basis.
So the amount of points that the data has
changed month on month.
And you can see a general trend there,
that over time, the changes have become
more muted, apart from obviously, the
COVID-19 economic shutdown globally, which
caused a big contraction in the official
China PMI survey.
So respondents reporting very wildly
negatively and then the bounce back
reporting very wildly positively.
So apart from that, if you look at the
entire data set from left to right, you
can see the changes month on month have
become a lot more muted.
Also in the download, we can compare the
official readings of the PMI versus
nominal GDP growth.
So you can see visually, there is a
relationship here between China official
PMI versus nominal GDP growth.
And we can inflation adjust using the CPI
data and we can get real GDP numbers.
That's all available in the spreadsheet.
And again, you can see visually, there is
a strong relationship between even the
official China PMI versus real GDP growth.
But remember, there's a weak correlation
with the Chinese index or Chinese indices.
So the read across into using the Chinese
index to gauge future economic growth with
an expectation that the index is going to
lead and go up and down based on this
data.
It's random.
It's almost 50-50.
Now, let's have a look at the Kaixin data.
This is where things get a little bit
interesting, because we can look at the
Kaixin data and start comparing periods of
history.
We can start comparing the Kaixin data to
the official data.
So again, this is where it gets a little
bit fruity, gets a little bit interesting,
and we can see what the Chinese government
is actually up to, and see the differences
between the two.
So again, if you look at the screen,
there's again, very obvious peaks and
drops.
You can see other than the bounce back
after the financial crisis, and at the end
of 09, beginning of 10, that we had
readings above 55.
We had some readings above 55 in the 07
year preceding, so 2006 and 2007, excuse
me, preceding the financial crisis.
So a few readings above 55 there, and a
reading above 55 at the beginning of 2005.
Other than those readings of 55, again,
apart from one blip in 2010, the last
decade, nothing above 55.
If you look at the period between 2011 up
until 2017, so towards the end of 2016,
2011 up until 2017, you'll see that
there's a lot of data in the Kaixin number
that's below 50.
And if you think back to this period, when
we looked at it on previous slides, and
you can look at this in the spreadsheets,
if you look back at this period and look
at the official number, there was
obviously a lot more readings during that
period from the official number above 50
than the Kaixin number.
So what's that saying?
Well, Kaixin IHS market PMI, the private
sector PMI, non-government, was reporting
in the PMI negative responses and
contraction a lot more during this period
than the official government statistics.
So this is definitely a period where, for
example, in the financial markets
community, everyone was constantly
questioning the validity of the Chinese
official data and whether they were lying
or not.
We're going to look at some of those
moments and look at differences very soon
in a lot more detail.
We also have the changes month on month
for the Kaixin China PMI.
You can see on the screen there, the data
for the changes on month on month.
So the point changes from the previous
month.
And when you think back to the changes
that were becoming more and more muted
from the official data,
the magnitude of the moves in the Kaixin
China PMI data hasn't really changed at
all.
The magnitude looks pretty consistent
throughout history.
We can also look at, obviously, the Kaixin
PMI data versus real GDP in China.
We've left nominal out here for now, but
you can look at that in the spreadsheet.
But what we've got on the screen here is
Kaixin PMI versus real GDP.
So adjusted for inflation.
And yes, you can see a very strong
relationship between the direction of the
two and Kaixin leading GDP, which is
reported later.
Now, this is where things get a little bit
interesting because we've actually got a
chart which plots the differences in the
Kaixin and the official manufacturing
data.
So if we look at the differences here,
what we've done is we've just minused the
official number off the Kaixin number.
So what does that mean?
Well, if the China official number is
reported as higher than the Kaixin number,
then we're going to get a negative reading
on the difference.
If it's reported lower, we're going to get
a positive reading on the difference.
So what does that mean?
Well, let's have a look at the data here.
You can see there's a lot more red bars in
the history versus positive green bars.
So the differences are in the majority
negative, meaning that the China official
PMI for the majority of the history of the
data has been reported for the month on
month change as higher than the Kaixin.
So what does that mean for us as traders
and portfolio managers?
Well, it basically means that we have to
take everything in the China official PMI
data that is in red.
We have to take it all with a big pinch of
salt.
So in any of those bars, when we had the
China official number, any of those bars
at those moments in time, any of those
bars that are red, we have to take the
official data with a big grain of salt and
read into it that it was actually
potential lies.
And what does it mean going forward?
Well, it means that we genuinely can't
have a lot of confidence in the official
data in using it to forecast Chinese GDP.
Now, we always like to go a little bit
further at ITPM to try and get to the
bottom of things to get to the truth.
So everything you're seeing here in the
red, we would label as potential lies
because we're essentially just minusing
official of Kaixin and the official is
registered as higher.
So if you look at it from the perspective
of the Chinese government and look at a
motive behind why they would potentially
lie, well, if the Kaixin is actually
becoming as a contractionary number or
reports a contractionary number below 50,
but then the official number is reported
as above 50.
So what they're basically saying in their
motive is that they don't want the world
to think that the Chinese manufacturing
sector is actually contracting.
Now, we always like to go a little bit
further at ITPM, do some digging, get to
the bottom of things and reveal the truth.
So we know what's really going on in
economies.
If you think of the context of when the
Chinese government might be lying, well,
the motive to lie is most likely to occur,
obviously, when the Kaixin number is
showing contraction.
And the Chinese government doesn't want
the world to think that the Chinese
manufacturing sector is going to contract.
So they report a number of growth.
So report a number above 50.
On the previous screen, we just looked at
the Kaixin number minus the official
number, regardless of what the numbers
were.
And we tracked that data and we saw that
there's a lot more in the negative.
We've done the same here.
But what we've also done is isolated the
times in the historical data where the
official PMI was reported above 50 and the
Kaixin PMI was reported below 50.
And you can see this visually on the chart
with the yellow bars.
So we're in the negative where we have the
official being reported as higher than the
Kaixin.
But it's at moments in time when the
official number is above 50 and higher
than Kaixin and Kaixin is below 50 showing
contraction.
So this is basically the Chinese
government telling you that they don't
want you to think that the manufacturing
sector is contracting in China.
This in the yellow bars is what we can
call as trainers and PMs, definite lies.
So naughty, naughty, naughty CCP.
If we look at the data set going right
back to 2005, we can see if we look
visually at the yellow bars, they lied
once in 2005.
They lied a few times coming out of the
financial crisis.
We have a big cluster in that period we
looked at earlier, 2011 to end of 2012.
We have a big cluster there where the
Kaixin PMI was showing contraction below
50 and the Chinese government was just
outright lying for a long time.
But their respondents were not responding
negatively, but responding positively in
the manufacturing sector.
So again, this is where we get a big
cluster and a lot of discrepancies.
And actually for the for the whole period
from 2011 up till 2017, there's a lot of
these moments where the Kaixin PMI is
reporting contraction, negative responses
from the manufacturing purchasing managers
and the official data is reporting
expansion above 50.
It's just outright lies.
What's also interesting is a more recent
moment in history where we get a lot of
negative readings in both Kaixin and
official number during 2019,
where basically the Kaixin number was
reported higher a lot of times than the
official number, even though many of those
numbers were negative.
And you can see this represented on the
screen with the green bars in 2019.
But what's interesting is when COVID
happened, the red bar that you're looking
at there is March 2020.
And the yellow bar is April 2020.
So they were potentially lying with the
official data in March 2020.
But they were definitely lying in April
2020, when they reported an expansion,
expansionary responses from the
manufacturing sector.
And the Kaixin was reporting a
contraction, so negative responses.
Again, you can see that visually via the
yellow bar.
That's April 2020.
And then afterwards, we have this period
in 2020 where they seem to be telling the
truth again.
So yeah, interesting period in history.
If you think of all the green bars going
back throughout history and compare that
to the 2019-2020 period,
maybe they started telling the truth.
But going forward, we'll find out.
Now something else we can look at in
China, as with any economic region, we can
look at the government bond market and we
can look at interest rates.
So our money market leading indicators,
but located in China.
And if we look at the government bond
market, China is actually the world's
second largest government bond market
behind the US.
And the bond market there in China is 16
trillion US dollars equivalent in
issuance.
And approximately 98.5% of China's
government bond market remains onshore and
it's denominated in renminbi, so RMB.
And there's no access allowed at all at
this moment in time by international
investors.
You know, that might change in the future.
But as of the time of recording, no
international investors can trade or
invest in Chinese government bonds.
And because of this, again, it's difficult
to use Chinese government bonds as a proxy
or leading indicator to Chinese GDP or
index direction and returns.
So from a trader's and portfolio manager's
perspective, when there's little to no
private market, it makes the yield or the
risk of the debt
in terms of price discovery fairly
meaningless to us.
The best we can do here, guys, in China is
look at real interest rates.
We can get interest rate data and CPI data
going back to the year 2000.
And we can look at interest rates adjusted
for inflation and therefore look at real
rates in China.
So you'll see this data in the spreadsheet
file in the downloads area.
The file that you're looking for is called
China real rates.
And here we've got the China real 10 year
rate.
So using the 10 year benchmark rate minus
the CPI all items.
And you can have a look at that data
yourself in the downloads area in the
spreadsheet.
What we've also done is charted the
Chinese real 10 year rate versus the US
real 10 year rate as well.
And what's interesting about this data, if
you look at it visually, when we make the
comparison, you can see there's a pretty
tight relationship between the two.
And except in very recent history in the
data set at the time of recording, where
there's a big discrepancy between US
negative real rates and very high real
rates in comparison in China.
Maybe just maybe they may be lying about
their inflation data.
Who knows?
I'll leave that up to you to decide.
Now, just as a reminder, seeing as though
we're covering real interest rates here in
China.
This information was from the video
earlier in the PTM video series on real
interest rates when we were covering them
in the US.
And if you recall, real interest rates in
their differing forms are the real price
or cost of money.
All things being equal, if money is
cheaper, market participants are going to
borrow more of it.
And when it's expensive, they're going to
borrow less of it.
And what were the implications that we
looked at?
So, cheaper money or relatively cheaper
money than before.
We get more borrowing plus more liquidity.
And that leads to inflationary conditions
and expansionary GDP.
Relatively expensive money from the
previous period leads to less borrowing
plus less liquidity and deflationary
conditions and contractionary GDP.
In terms of equity market volatility, when
we have relatively cheaper money, we get
less volatility in the equity markets and
higher liquidity.
When we have relatively more expensive
money.
money, we tend to get more equity market
volatility and liquidity goes down.
Now, when we think of real rates in the
Chinese context and from a trader's and
portfolio manager's perspective, we
generally can't use Chinese real rates as
a leading indicator to predictably
forecast equity market direction and
volatility and also central bank policy.
So, why is that the case?
Well, if you think of our five points that
we made earlier, where we covered
potential GDP manipulation from the
Chinese government, the fact that there's
no pensions infrastructure in China, the
fact that there's middle class problems
and demographic headwinds, and also the
equity market is very closed to foreign
purchases.
So, it basically means that the indices
will probably not behave predictably in
response to real rate decreases and
increases.
Also, when it comes to central authorities
in China.
in China or central bank policy, it
doesn't work like it does in the US with
the Fed and the dual mandate.
The CCP is political and they control the
money supply and the debt market
predicting from a traders and portfolio
managers perspective what these guys are
going to do next based on Western ideals
is a naive step.
So, for China, we just have to assume that
if the government is manipulating interest
rates higher or lower than them more than
likely active in the bond market.
So, what we can do as traders and PMs, we
can keep an eye on the Kaixin China
manufacturing PMI on a monthly basis and
we can look at the difference between the
Kaixin data and the official data and stay
on top of Chinese real rates.
And if we use them all together, we're
having a very good effort in getting a
sense of expansion and contraction
prospects for the Chinese economy.
It's not ideal, but it's the best we can
do.
So, let's summarize this now with China
and the Kaixin PMI and China real rates
data.
How is it useful to us as traders and PMs?
Well, of course, if we follow it, we keep
up to date with it, we're going to get a
much more accurate picture of China's GDP
growth prospects and the direction of GDP
in terms of expansion or contraction.
And it's going to help us form our global
macro view and understand the relative GDP
growth prospects and potential stock
market returns in different geographies.
And we can use the data to predict future
revenue and earnings that are changing at
US companies that have large exposure to
the Chinese market.
We can also use the information to
potentially generate trade ideas in
Chinese stocks that are listed on the New
York Stock Exchange and NASDAQ as American
depository receipts that have very high
revenue and earnings exposure inside
China.
So, again, we go to our ADR full list at
the source, their top foreign stocks,
which, of course, may change in the
future.
So, get good at your Google search terms.
You'll always find sources that have all
of the listed ADRs and the Chinese ADRs
are available there at the time of
recording.
We can also use the information to
generate trade ideas in areas of the
global markets that rely heavy on Chinese
demand in sectors such as the mining
sector, metals, autos, chemicals,
construction, energy stocks that exist on
exchanges in other countries and trade as
ADRs in US dollars on US dollar exchanges.
And again, we have the full foreign ADR
list there.
So, we're not necessarily just looking at
Chinese ADRs.
We can look at, for example, European
ADRs.
So, European companies that have ADR
listings in the US and they have large
exposure to the Chinese economy.
Now, we also know that because of China's
heavy export dependence on the US and the
EU, that if we see a slowdown in the US
and the EU PMIs, that this is going to
show up in the Chinese PMIs in the future.
So, we can potentially take positions in
Chinese ADRs based on our analysis of both
US and European PMIs.
What we can also do is take positions in
Chinese ADRs based on our statistical
analysis of the manipulation of Chinese
GDP and also the manipulation of the
official data versus the Caxin PMI.
Because we know when we spot the lie, when
we spot the fraud, that the reality that's
going on is different.
Okay.
The fantasy GDP stats and the fantasy PMI
stats from the official number are
probably not going to show up in Chinese
company earnings.
So, Chinese companies that are listed on
US exchanges because of US reporting
standards.
So, for example, if we see the lie evolve
in the PMIs or we suspect that GDP stats
have been heavily manipulated or they're
going to be heavily manipulated.
If Chinese ADRs go up on this information
by a lot, we know that the Chinese
companies can't lie about their earnings
like the government has lied in the
official PMI data or with the GDP number.
So, we can potentially look for short
positions there when we recognize them,
when we recognize what's going on.
Additionally, with Chinese stocks, Chinese
ADRs, there's a lot of accounting fraud.
So, it's not just the Chinese government
that exaggerates or bends the truth or
lies about GDP growth and PMI data.
But Chinese companies themselves
repeatedly have been caught a lot in
specific accounting fraud to their
companies.
So, we can, of course, also look to
potentially take short positions or have
put option structure positions in Chinese
ADRs that are exhibiting company specific
accounting fraud.
And just as a reminder, be careful when
you're looking at Chinese ADRs, make sure
that the ADR you're looking at is a listed
ADR.
So, listed on exchange.
And it's tradable.
And it's tradable in your retail trader
account.
And it's not an over-the-counter
instrument.
Even better, of course, if it's listed.
And there's listed equity options
available as well.
Okay.
So, that just about wraps it up, guys.
So, for the Chinese leading indicators,
the Kaixin China PMI compared to the
official PMI.
And also with China real rates.
We're going to head straight into the next
video now.
And we're going to do a recap of all of
our leading indicators.
We'll see you next time.